welcome to this video round 5 and the
final round of the Zurich chest
challenge yeah this is a really quick
tournament fire France it feels like it
has just begun and now it's ending after
five rounds let's look at the games the
situation before this final round is
that cards misleading with three and a
half out of four followed by ronnian
with three out of four both fantastic
results and both the tournament leaders
are playing with black today Aronian
with black against karana & Carlson
playing black against Arnold so both um
with a difficult task with the black
pieces and the third game in a camera
against Gelfond to play us some
certainly want to forget the tournament
rather quickly now camera had an
excellent first half of the tournament
it's pretty much exactly up to about
round to move 30 against the against the
reigning world champion when he had a
completely winning position against
scars and blundered it to to a loss even
it could have been a brilliant
tournament for the American but so it's
um the way it went it just was it was
some yeah it was some real letdown after
losing against Carlton even lost against
Aronian following day so now he's on
minus one even and Gelfond yeah he also
had a bad tournament let's see what
happens Nakamura a fall and Del Fonda
sticking to his guns he has prepared to
the specially God for the World
Championship mentioned he is some aiming
for that constantly but people very
rarely play d4 against him 93 it's like
I'm worse choice choice and that's a
good move if you want to avoid the
chouette Nick off
and at the same time you don't want to
play Bishop b5 there are two main entire
session akov moves this one rassoul emo
on 93 and that's his ribs still keep the
option open to play deform if black
plays a move like is six for example
you're still can transpose to the open
sian while at the same time avoiding the
trash Nick off yeah why is it avoiding
this reznikoff yeah well Knight f6 is a
move if you go now deform you have it
again so what is why it's idea the point
is that after Knight f6 CM White has
some yeah in fact he has more than one
interesting move the main argument
against this Knight f6 Bishop b5
actually this line is believed to be
somewhat better for white it's not
entirely clear it's a complicated matter
but wyd usually accepts this line one
point being that after Knight d4 d5 is
possible with very sharp play um this
can be recommended for white players so
what are rational of players doing here
mostly they play what golf and plate d5
yeah this is some also in the spirit of
the shrestha cough ignoring the d5
square but on the other hand
establishing very strong control over
deform and then general having them yes
solid foothold in the center this line
could be very easily predicted by
Nakamura by choosing efore it was rather
likely to have this position and to be
honest I think just my personal opinion
that he was aiming for this line to get
a very safe position and well if not the
risk much if girlfriend is doing
somethings you could maybe play
otherwise just stay very solid Bishop c4
very logical and Bishop e7 yeah this is
meant to control g5
from liquid go here you need to be aware
that night g5 is a very embarrassing
move this is controlling g5 d3 and now
Knight f6 is possible as my GF can be
answered with castles however Knight d2
is played yeah this is an online at the
known maneuver the knight on f3 is not
so well placed what white is trying to
do is to use it only three to control d5
better or sometimes on g3 but normally
to e3 it's all about the d5 square yeah
black place t69 f1 and now Bishop to g4
yeah this is a recent idea attacking the
Queen and provoking the move f3 f3 is
not necessarily a nice move to make
white is weakening the dark squares a
lot and t4 fades some options that you
would would have without the move like
Queen a three for example at some stage
yeah and what if he does not want to
play a three what what are you playing
yeah it only leaves the move Queen d2
this makes a somewhat yet impression but
this is not a big problem this Queen
position can be corrected on the other
hand I really don't believe that this is
something particularly great for white
black certain dear is ok here you plate
97 this is a useful regrouping the night
was supposed to go to be 6 and by
freeing this Bishop you at the right
moment allow Bishop g5 this is
especially a valid if white moves the
Queen at some point I mean the queen is
at the moment controlling the square
supported by the bishop but of course it
cannot stay there forever and once the
Queen moves there is Bishop g5 coming
this also applies after 95 but should be
693 now the bishop is moved to g5 and
this is also clear that the night on
everyone cannot stay there forever it
was always destined to go to e3 so here
we go and Bishop g5 and this is very
similar to a game of girl fans from the
title co tournament against Wesley so
where he lost rather quickly no I think
this game is a slight improvement on
move 9 in the soul game midnight beast
Knight b6 and he played Bishop e-cig so
this is maybe a small refinement Bishop
g5 has mentioned and now I played c3 gap
it's hard to UM get along without this
move it controls important squares and
it if possible allows a place for the
bishop yeah black plays castles and
queen d 1 so white corrects this Queen
position after all I am not really
impressed with the opening play by by
white I mean I think Malcolm early
didn't didn't want to to do so much in
this game to be honest in general I
don't think that this line should
promise white much black it's just very
solid the d5 squares is something but
black especially if you have solved the
issue of this slightly passive Bishop
black has no problems at all might be
six threading a piece of 55 and again
taking only six yeah thus capture only
six is certainly debatable as you
strengthen or let's say you alter the
pawn structure so that these six pawn is
controlling d5 an f5 it's not what you
really want to do but what exactly is
your alternative how in black am
can easily kill him take on e3 and play
d5 and if you're let's say for example
by white wood castle yeah just a simple
simple move black will take if
everything else fails you do that you
take play d 5 no just I will and this in
this position I'm only black can be
better to be honest sg3 might be a
slight weakness note that black took on
b6 with the pawn this is especially oops
sorry this is especially useful if you
look at this type of structure sc5 is
securely protected so white basically
needs to react to this threat taking and
d5 white could play 95 just to show it
and then black takes yeah place 97 and
you simply exchange everything off
that's appearing on d5 and this is your
equalizing strategy very easy play for
black no problems at all yeah this is
what nakamura played and queen bee three
to attack this and to take attack this
yeah and black just just reacts with the
most active move and the best move d5
just pushing yeah this is not a very
lucky PCM it does not have any useful
role the problem is if you take him no
black can take only three so recapture
and now black can even consider to take
with the Queen it's some not bad at all
attacking here no I have no problems
black also can take with oops can take
with the pawn and have no problems
whatsoever I mean isn't this a nice
center I think black can be very
satisfied here yeah that's the problem
you do you cannot really take without
conceding yeah at least equality to
black he played castles and King h8 we
are getting out of this sensitive
diagonal now white plate a for fixing on
the light squares which is a good idea
yeah add to this position now Gelfond
plate night a five taking the Queen and
went to be five the most active move and
now knight c6 okay Jim how does some
whites play for an advantage him it's
very difficult I mean I'm sure that
maybe nakamura head or looked for some
ways to continue the game he always
tries even if he wants to play it safe
by his standards but it's very difficult
to play something else than queen bee
three what what exactly is why it's
planned Black is even better in the
center we controls more space you went
back and therefore accepted to the draw
basically black also has a hard time to
deviate if ya what what should like do
if not Knight a5
you know you only have strange moves
available to be honest you want to cover
here note that if let's say um let's say
black plays nothing move just to show
the point then 85 is something something
else after taking white can take here
this is a big difference with castles
being played so the d5 pawn is really
threatened and while 9 a-5 draws the
game and do you really want to play flag
97 instead let's have a look Joe it's
quite embarrassing and white emerges
with the better structure yeah so we had
one of those positions where it's
difficult for both sides to avoid the
draw so in the game after night f5 turn
here exactly they agreed to a draw yeah
I guess both players didn't mind that
too much just my personal opinion
because they both had at the end a bad
tournament and I probably glad that the
classical part at least is over where
they can ditch for the rating points the
event is not over there's a rapid
tournament tomorrow so this is some in
general I mean this is also important
for the players but far more but I guess
light-hearted compared to compared to
this okay let's go to the second game
unarmed Carson let's see what the world
champion can do in this game against his
son
predecessor yeah Bishop b5 the Roy just
like in the match and Carson again asked
the question what are you going to do
against this opening the Berlin defense
do you have any great idea and what is
I'm not playing d3 Bishop c5 Bishop c6
again the some rather simplistic line
that however yesterday netted cars in a
very nice win against kawana with the
exactly this move h3 yeah yeah so that's
the best that white can get in this
opening I understand why black players
choosing this over and over again this
really feels like a walk in the park
compared to many other defenses okay
council plays 97 and keeps the bishop
yeah let's miss make sense he wants to
keep the bishop down and prepare
possible c5 later yeah all those fields
really logical it has been played before
yeah d former by Anand yeah this now
leads the game into a structure typical
of the exchange 3 takes Queen takes
typical off the exchange with wear black
has got four points against three on the
queenside but it's got the double pawn
which means that white basically is a
porn up on the King side which is worth
more than blacks and double pawn on the
other hand black has scott of course the
bishop am and he's got a very easy
development in the game Carlton played c
5 23 and now be six now we see
blacks the development concept he wants
to put the bishop on b7 to increase the
pressure on the pawn on e4 and he also
has night g6 away Logan maybe night h4
so black has very easy piece play and
yeah what is doing now he's simply
taking on d6 your ok quindi 626 cd6 and
root d 1 so yeah why does some giving up
this pawn and the text e6 so we got this
yeah and this of course this is the game
I'm just playing it this is of course
realest newsam I mean it's probably yeah
the the dallas game that I've covered
for for quite a while they just did the
just traded all pieces which is in a way
an understandable thing I mean aunt
didn't have the great tournament however
he won a game yesterday it's not yeah he
certainly would have loved to to win
this here against God but he obviously
does not have anything against the
Berlin and he was just putting its
pieces on normal squares and see what
happens and he had nothing and then
decided to to just kill the game off
they continued for a while it's not like
they agreed to draw immediately but term
we're in in the type of position where
actually I'm every every decent player
would get a draw against top level
opposition yeah even the night self they
they shuffle for a while
and here draw a grid yeah okay not very
exciting but as I mentioned in a way
understandable cows already has
accomplished a fantastic result with
plus three out of five games against
this opposition and has some gained some
more rating points to put his rating to
an all-time high so what what should you
do I mean he just places this opening
and says okay if you don't have anything
we draw if you have some interesting try
we will get a fighting game it's not my
job as black to to do something great
iam so I'm a very very understandable
approach but this also means with the
draw that aronian with a win could
actually equalize Wisconsin so let's see
what he did take black against kawana no
easy task of course and Ronan is always
playing a five-dollar king porn and we
get to a root which is not happening all
the time in Kiwanis games he also plays
the scotch and some rare Alliance from
time to time but here we get to an
absolute main line and in fact this is
all slightly slightly surprising that
karana is actually allowing the marshal
but I think it's a good sign white
players for a very long time they try to
to get something in entire marshal lines
like d 3 or 5 d 3 and so on this very
slow lines and it's not really
endangering black too much and I always
thought that the truth or some if there
is something in the opening then it
should be in the main line marshal I'm
not an expert on this opening but I
really every don't believe that what can
get anywhere with see 3d three
c3 of course but not with d3 a 3h three
this kind of very slow stuff it's
certainly okay you can do that but you
certainly not get get an advantage okay
d5 the Marshall which is erroneous main
weapon but it also means that as
paradoxical as it sounds that it's very
likely that he will have problems to win
the game it's simply that the Marshall
needs to at first first look too very
sharp positions but they are so heavily
analyzed that it's usually steered
towards positions where black has very
little winning chances we see some of
that in the game um here can wanna play
d 3 as far as i know this is the modern
main line here not d for any more as
they played in and former times this
kind of line is the old the old main
line of them of the Marshall d3 is more
popular nowadays 56 rook e1 and Bishop
f5 yeah blacks compensation in the
Marshall is based on his good
development and yeah whites sometimes
clumsy pieces they are still in the
corner it takes a while until they are
really participating and black is very
quick with pushing pieces towards the
Kings side like Queen a three-year right
the Queen edge for attacking the
sensitive age 2 square yeah Queen FIA
you always need to check this check and
now something on the e-file yeah and
this leads to disaster like it's just
winning with an attack so white white
cannot take he must play g3 Queen to h3
now this queen is protecting
five yeah and white now needs to get his
stuff he developed I mean very quickly
so he plays Bishop e3 and gives up the
d3 Square and porn sorry black took it
and 92 so what has some what has
happened in the last couple of moves
writers returned his extra pawn but in
the meantime he gains some time for his
development and maybe even is able to
centralize this night another point is
that white at some point might take on
d5 and establish a good bishop on deform
we see after Queen f5 bishop d for this
is a new move according to my database
at least and some Martian experts might
might might say that well this was
played in a correspondence game and here
and there this is very likely actually
the Marchioness so heavily analyzed that
the normal source is like my Mecca
database um is probably insufficient to
really this has what is the history
behind them behind those moves rook e8
and a four yeah this is some very
standard White's idea here is that
blacks pawns are somewhat advanced and
therefore also slightly weak it's
playing for very small nuances and we
see that after first h6 I'm sorry kingi
to king of eight my notes I read read my
notes from king of a jack rook trade
trade here also this and this and this
transformation is fairly typical of the
of the Marshall and the reason why quite
often the Marshall leads into end games
that are
very difficult to win for black in fact
quite often it leads to end games were
blacks upon down but has compensation
with the bishops it's not exactly a
great result I think in the opening for
aronian he can at best hope for a draw I
mean he has certainly justified hopes to
reach this strong but it's not much fun
and white can try for ages 2 to win he's
got those two pawns as targets and what
is very nice he's got a position with
well-defined outpost for his pieces the
nice bishop on d4 always covered by the
pond and the night can be regrouped to
e3 attacking d5 it's I think it was very
difficult to avoid this end game if we
scroll back a couple of moves it is
difficult to suggest something else of
like him you could yeah you can choose
some other yeah let's say other
transformations of the position you can
for example here if you want to avoid
this capture you could take for example
but this is this is helping wide I mean
there's 95 may be in the position or
there are other things that that are
problematic here sometimes it's a be a
be and rook a 6 let's say black is
playing a nothing cleanser here now
here's even Bishop b5 a problem getting
those exchange also would help white
enormously yeah add some it's slightly
uncomfortable but it's hard for me
without any theoretical knowledge to
assess them the exact exact position
what I know is that or I'm pretty sure
about is that this is a
convenient end game it's a I think in
many cases black will draw but it's not
much fun to play and this type of
position is actually the reason why I
never bothered to study the Marshall
attack it's it's in lots of lines if Y
term cooperates black gets very very
nice really attacking play which is very
attractive to study but if white knows
what he's doing you quite often get this
type of endgame which is to be honest
just a bit depressing it's a not very of
it's not fun to play and yeah yeah I
don't know I don't like it but it's
something that you get in the Marshall
it's not it's not avoidable really let's
see there should be seven night f1 and
93 yep like suddenly did well to
exchange at least one of the pawns okay
five now d 5 will be gone the question
is how to defend after the loss of the
pawn I can put some more moves on the
board and that's it's taken what I think
is that a romance next maneuver it's not
really it's not really great but it's
this is very difficult a very difficult
type of position to analyze because if
you if you play this in a game you see
whites foster slowly crawling towards
you why does making slow but steady
progress and it's very difficult to find
a clear drawing setup it's it's almost
impossible to do because why this very
well coordinated they all protect each
other or pieces and you don't have a
clear drawing idea
I mean what would be great to exchange
the dark squared bishop against the
night to get opposite colored bishops
but this is not easy to accomplish what
aronian is doing is he puts the bishop
on c1 and I think that this might be a
mistake might be might be I was thinking
that maybe it's better to keep it on
this diagonal just retreated and this
Bishop keeping on this diagonal so that
denied on f5 might be captured at the
right moment not sure what this right
moment looks like it does not look right
but what I was trying to to get it with
this move Bishop see one he has the
problem just a couple of moves later
that this Bishop can sometimes be
exchanged against the bishop this is
happening he played Luke a8g for okay to
King g3 or logical and here all of a
sudden we get to this position I mean
maybe here what's the point where you
needed to to to drop the bishop back I
don't know this is definitely problem
because now after the tsongas check who
should f to the bishops i exchanged and
after the bishop trade black is i think
almost lost I mean this check this I'm
pretty confident about that like is in
big trouble here the night and rook are
very well coordinated the C porn is
dangerous and white can even make more
progress on the kingside this pawn
structure it's not helpful check this
snow is very very nice technique by
kawana King gets activated and h5 fixing
the structure black is never going to
move any of those pawns and now it's M
question of slowly advancing the sea
porn and combining the sea porn with
threats against the king with a combined
attack of the night and the rook and
it's playing this very nicely look at
this check seafoam this is a very nice
move and maybe something that Aronian
didn't really appreciate the nice thing
is that if black no takes 9 p-7 is
winning very nice attacking the rook
attacking the bishop and if the rook is
protecting the bishop check there's the
fork very nice so it needed tool and it
only has this terrible square 97 check
and 96 that's it g7 is gone so like it's
lost he continued for a while but it's
basically hopeless the combined attack
here is too much chat white is winning
check all the pawns check and at the end
can organize this pawn roller up to up
to g6 and here our own young resigned he
has absolutely no defense against the g7
rook evade so how to assess this game
it's not so easy it's somewhere I think
and this makes it difficult for me to
analyze this is almost a theoretical
question of opening theory because
around here I think Blackie I mean I
don't know the opening but somewhere
around here and the next couple of moves
I think black must must do something
else because the rising endgame is is so
uncomfortable I cannot believe that
like should should allow that I mean can
if you look at this this type of endgame
I mean this is just for some some
players this would be a wet dream I mine
gif gift cards in this position in each
white game until you reach 3000 rating
probably it's just a it's just very
uncomfortable to to play this position
so there must be some improvement our
black must find some improvement before
that but i'm not i'm not entirely sure
where this might be it it does not feel
like black should be in trouble here so
I don't think that kawana has refuted
the Marshall attack but it's hard for me
to to suggest something unless I'm over
estimating channel White's play in the
end game maybe I'm doing that it says
it's possible lots of end games of this
type um black relatively easily holds
but this looks it looks ugly to me and
why it has very nice piece coordination
so for me it's a question of a possible
improvement around TM and of course in
the end game around here maybe this this
night this Bishop maneuver this was
certainly not a successful accessible
successful regrouping but I don't really
think that if you would stay passive
like this generally stay on this
diagonal in the long run it will be a
book be very problematic for black but
it's just very well coordinated you get
the rook over here g4 h5 possibly night
f5 and don't forget the passer here in
the Seaport very uncomfortable
decision so this is what does this mean
Carlton has won the tournament no
surprise there but with Carlton being on
+ 3 + aronian losing the last round
cards nom has even won this thing was
one point ahead of Aronian very
convincing victory at the end he had
this very shaky game of course against
nakamura should not forget that but he
won three games don't don't forget the
other wins and those were very nice
games he was a beat kawana very
convincingly for example a very nice
game I thought almost perfectly played
so I'm a good performance by the by the
world champion overall yeah tomorrow
will be the final day of this event a
rapid event they usually i dont kappa
rapid events but i have a look through
the games play tomorrow if there are
some interesting moments i might do a
small video about that yeah i hope
you've enjoyed the coverage of this
tournament i'm not one hundred percent
sure if there is some big event in
February if there isn't the next I think
there is sub tournament in bham bham
that I might do something about but ok
what I certainly cover is the candidates
which will be in March and this will of
course be very very interesting ok
thanks for watching